What is it? A beacon. They're sending
a message. A message to where
Welcome back everyone this is going to be my
new eternals video all about the connection
to the shang chi post credit scene the ten rings
the celestials in the rings that phastos creates
to form the uni-mind if you're brand new to the
channel be sure to subscribe to get all the videos
we're going to get a brand new spiderman no way
home trailer next week there's a whole bunch of
stuff coming up quick spoiler warning for the
eternals movie and for the shang chi movie if
you have not seen either of those films because
we have to talk about the post-credits scenes for
both of those movies as well as the entire plot of
the eternals film but since the eternals movie has
been released a lot of you have been asking me
if there was a connection between the celestial
rings that phastos creates to form the uni-mind
and the 10 rings from the shang chi movie because
they look kind of similar in the energy that they
give off looks almost the same they aren't exactly
the same but they do seem very similar during
the shang chi post-credits scene wang and hulk
revealed that their research has told them that
the ten rings are ancient way beyond a thousand
years so they were created long before the
mandarin ever found them on planet earth
how long did your dad have them before he gave
them to you about a thousand years their thermal
luminescence indicates they're older than that by
a lot they aren't listed as artifacts or relics
in the library of comartage and relics as they
explained during the doctor strange movie are
just items that contain magic that's too powerful
for them to wield without binding it to items
they've only begun to explore the power of the ten
rings but you kind of learn through the course of
the film that the mandarin was never using them to
their full ability like when shang chi goes full
dragon ball on the dweller in darkness that's
meant to be a taste of their full power but the
idea that he'll learn to use them even better by
the time we get to shang chi to the sequel movie
so he's just barely beginning to tap their
potential so they channel crazy cosmic energy
they date before the time of agamotto because
there are no records of them in karmartage and
agamotto was the first sorcerer supreme and on top
of that they don't resemble any alien technology
in the main mcu universe as captain marvel says
they're not vibranium chitauri not like any alien
tech i've seen basically what she's saying is that
the ten rings are not from the main mcu universe
they've been transmitting a beacon since shang
chi used them to kill the dweller in darkness even
though they don't say that literally it's implied
that the beacon in them only started transmitting
recently when he started using them it wouldn't
have been transmitting for the last thousand years
while the mandarin was using them and during
the movie when they go to the tahloe alternate
dimension his mother sister his aunt played by
michelle yo tells him the backstory of her people
from this alternate dimension and how the dweller
in darkness eradicated their race until the great
protector dragon intervened to defeat it and its
soul eaters in the way she talks about it this was
an ancient cosmic war that took place over a very
long period of time it was all happening inside
this alternate dimension of ta lo in their village
inside this ta lo dimension was constructed around
one of the gateways between their universe in the
main mcu universe if it wasn't clear that's why
the great protector dragon trapped the dweller
in darkness in that specific mountain range
because it was about to pass through the gateway
into the main mcu universe and pull pullador mamu
just go through the process of slowly taking over
the multiverse one dimension at a time dormammu
had a different way of doing it like he absorbed
other dimensions into his dark dimension but it's
the same basic premise taking over the multiverse
one universe at a time and all their people in the
village even though they've been living here for
many many generations are all very familiar with
the ten rings themselves as if it's all just old
hat like oh yeah the ten rings we know all about
that in marvel comics the people who created the
ten rings were the mcluhan's the race of beings
the space dragons that fing fang foom comes from
but during the movie their version of mcu thing
fang fume is basically the great protector dragon
so i think one they're trying to tell us that the
dragon represents the mcu race of makluans and
their race are the ones that created the ten rings
and here's where i think the rings themselves
connect with the eternals celestial rings that
phastos creates early theory i think that
the great protector dragon is really just
a celestial from another dimension from this
ta low dimension yes he looks like a dragon he
doesn't look like arishem the judge or the other
main celestials like teemut issa and the searcher
but ego the living planet is the best example
that all celestials do not have to look
exactly the same they can take different forms and
we're just talking about celestials from the main
marvel universe and if the great protector
dragon is a celestial from another universe
then it's much easier to explain why it looks
so different there's also another easter egg
sort of backing up my theory here so if you watch
the chinese language dub of the shang chi movie
during that they actually call the great protector
dragon something different its real name is
actually the dragon god like it's meant to be
a full-on god level being worshipped by shang
chi's mother's people in their dimension i don't
know why they didn't want to call it the dragon
god in the english language version of the movie
maybe they didn't want to upset religious groups
or something like that but during the eternals
movie the eternals talk about the celestials
irish and the judge as if they're actual gods the
way they talk about it during the movie they say
they feel like they've been abandoned by their god
when they pick up in present day because it's been
so long since arishem the judge has contacted them
the real reason why he didn't do that was because
they were just waiting for tiamat to fully absorb
enough cosmic energy to hatch and it just took
thousands of years for earth's population to reach
a point to where that could happen so that's why i
think the ten rings were created by the celestials
from the ta lo dimension and that's why they're so
ancient that kamar taj has no records of them but
they look kind of similar and the energy they give
off when shanxi uses them is only just a little
bit different than the brighter yellow cosmic
energy of the uni-mind when they're all channeling
it into cersei in taking it a step further what
does this all mean what are they trying to imply
what are they setting up in the background a
couple of years ago before they'd revealed the
marvel phase 4 movie slate james gunn and kevin
feige said the future of the mcu was going in
a super cosmic direction and right after the
eternals movie came out i did this big video about
what the writers were setting up for the sequel
movie the writers teased that they were setting up
this huge cosmic war involving the celestials so
during the shang chi post credit scene when they
talk about this signal that the ten rings are
broadcasting who where is it broadcasting to these
ancient rings that are supposed to be from another
dimension they're probably broadcasting that
signal to the celestials of the ta lo dimension or
other celestial like beings and we'll just learn
more about those beings in the truth of the ten
rings in shang chi 2 the sequel movie in what's
going on with the other dragon gods from this
other dimension the way that michelio's character
talked about this ancient war with the dweller in
darkness she made it seem like the great protector
dragon was the only celestial level being that
intervened on their behalf but she didn't confirm
that it was the only celestial in their dimension
is he wearing the rings he hasn't
taken them off since she died
what do they have to do with all this so just
more evidence more background easter eggs the
way they're adapting this that make it seem
like these dragon level celestial beings from
this other ta lo dimension are the ones who
created the ten rings and if we're talking
about the future of the marvel cosmic universe
i think eventually they'll spin this story that
they're teasing into a much larger cosmic
war between different groups of celestials
which is a huge part of the history of
the marvel cosmic universe in the comics
the funny thing about the eternals movie is a lot
of the twists in revealing how arishem the judge
lies about a lot of their history in the history
of the universe arishem says that he actually
pre-dates the universe he pre-dates the infinity
stones or the singularities that eventually would
form the infinity stones but he also says that he
created the first sun that led to the creation of
the first galaxy and then so on and so forth until
the other celestials were born from the cosmic
seeds that he planted in different worlds the real
story is the irish and the judge was created by
eternity so yes he may have been the first
celestial but he had to be created by someone
else and that someone was eternity the living
embodiment of the universe and the multiverse
eventually we learn about these dark celestials
in the comics that predated the current celestials
they called them the aspirants there was a giant
cosmic war between them so i think that they're
trying to slowly adapt a version of this in
the movies but it'll be very different and
i think that they're trying to tease this war
taking place across different dimensions like
different groups of celestials going to war with
each other eventually they mentioned the concept
of eternity several times during the charles movie
but they never talk about it as if it's an actual
character so just remains to be seen how they're
going to pay that off in future marvel movies
i just did a galactus video because the eternals
writers were talking about using galactus in
future eternals movies he's not a celestial but
he's something on the level of celestials like
he is a cosmic threat to the celestials there
are other things out there that are capable of
killing celestials as well like the horde is a
race of beings that feed on the cosmic energy
that the celestials are made of so a lot of
people ask how do you go bigger than avengers
end game in avengers infinity war while you take
it to this celestial level big giant cosmic war
between different dimensions really starting to
spin up into secret wars territory we'll get more
easter eggs for this setting it up in the sequel
movies but i don't think we'll actually see them
really paid off to like avengers 6 avengers 7
some future avengers movie but hopefully that
explains how the 10 rings are similar to phasto's
celestial rings but not exactly the same thing
still cosmic energy still created by celestial
level beings just from different dimensions
with them sort of changing the mcluhan's
in the comics to being these dragon god
celestials from another dimension if you have
any other questions about what's going on with
the eternals movie the celestials or the
shang chi movie in the 10 rings just write
it below in the comments and i'll add it to
my future bonus videos my next big spider-man
no way home trailer will post just as soon as
they drop it online make sure you have alerts
enabled for my channel so you don't miss that
everyone click here for that full marvel moon
knight trailer video and easter eggs and click here
for the new she hulk trailer video in easter eggs
thank you so much for watching everyone stay
safe and i'll see you guys in the next one!